[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde je dois avouer que
tout à l'heure j'étais super stressée
mais grâce à dieu la nourriture mavrodi
stressé alors j'ai pleuré parce que les
gens de même et pas j'ai essayé de faire
comme eux ils ne vont toujours pas m
j'ai pleuré parce que les gens ne
m'estimais pas autant que je voulais en
fait tout ce que je voulais c'était à
tout prix de plaire à tout le monde
je voulais à tout prix être accepté aux
yeux de tous quand j'étais enfin il ya
quelques années quand j'étais au collège
rassurez vous je ne mobile n'est pas de
vous raconter ma vie quand j'étais au
collège je détestais sérieusement matin
j'étais vraiment complexé et le pire
c'est qu'ils avaient des gens qui qui
passent leur temps à pirelli mini
pousses et petits modèles
du coup ça m'énerve est sérieusement
j'avais très envie d'être est lancée
parce que pour moi être parfait en fait
c est très lent cfoot solide cote est
donc j'avais très très très envie d'être
est lancé il m'arrivait même parfois de
refuser de rencontrer des gens que je
n'avais jamais vu parce que je supposais
qu'ils allaient me répéter la musique
est variable
ah ben tu parais grande sur des photos
mais pourtant tu es petit tu as ça remue
ça m'énervait sérieusement il m'a fallu
du temps pour comprendre que la
perfection n'est pas de ce monde et que
mon bonheur ne dépend que de moi tu sais
avant d'être à la recherche de cette
personne qui tu aimeras de toutes ses
forces
tu as besoin de te retrouver je te
tutoie par stone tutoyons je parle à
moi-même je parle à toi je parle à nous
il faut que tu comprennes combien de
fois il est si important de te chérir
pour mes deux fois il est si important
de chérir ton âme aribit malheureuse
avec toi même regarde toi tu es parfait
tu fais partie des meilleures créatures
divines
il faut que tu ta porte cet amour
inconditionnel donc tu as tant rêvé de
toi tu en rêvais à voir je ne te demande
en aucun cas d'être égoïste encore moins
arrogant je te rappelle jusqu il a
permis de perdre des gens mais ne fait
jamais l'horreur de peine ce que tu es
ne laisse jamais personne ni rien te
faire croire que tu n'en vaut pas la
peine ne laisse jamais personne de
détourner ou te dire que tu ne vaux rien
et qui que tu sois quoi que tu fasses où
que tu sois je te souhaite sincèrement
d'être heureux merci
[Applaudissements]